多分
4日
goo
あっほどっ
バッハん
me
wh
持っています
ん
かもよはぁ galaxy s 5が欲しいなぁ
俺そうだもんなぁ
バッハ
わーっ抜きで galaxy s 5です昔から見てるというのがわかると思うんです
けど僕は今までスマホアジャラ口でしか使ったことないですて熱いレース最初使って
ずっと水で壊れちゃって
で s 2になってドラッグシリーズ4 a は使ってるんですけどなんだで
ギャラクシーを使っているかといったら
なぜやっぱ使いやすいですよ早いし
個人的な意見なんですけどなんか iphone 使ってる人が多い気がしてちょっと
みんなといっしょが嫌だなぁと思ってキャラ9種を選んで
で使いやすくて結構ずっとギャラクシーですとも最新型の一切が出たということなんで
ん
見ていきましょう s アイルーのちょっと角ばってるカフェなんですけど
られ見たがあると思うんですけど s 5のほうがちょっとだけ大きいです
なんだツルツルしてるんですよねエナ選べるっていうか
sr ドラ名正近づ芸も強くて軽い pc gmt 呼ばれるからチェックみたいなど
を使っているらしいです
落とした時に衝撃を分散して5000円のがビーズを
軽くするらしいで galaxy s 5のすごいところは
ネットね俺の五ツボっと比べてもカメラがすごいボート4ますねめちゃ速いんです
今からお前らオートフォーカスするか用意した後
これぐらいの速さなんですけど僕の音 s 4はね
まあねっ結局ねっいきますよ用意スタート
これくらい違うんです
僕も数えてなかったらよくわかんないといっ先導でて押せばいい
一戦の自動しますね性能で
てくらい差があるんですよ galaxy s 4がだいたい1秒なんですけどこっち
のオート府は稼がね3秒ルールにできるんでカメラ機能は全く
s 5でかなり登場しています s ファイルでも行こうすごいと思って昨日はただ
チームとかでも見たことあると思うんですけど s バイブ電自我介に行ってきたら
ウルトラ省電力モードっつって画面が白黒になるんですよ
どうすか原点回帰白黒ですよついにこので黒字からた世界はもう過去へ帰ることという
かね
結局だね白黒 ai いってね前人の持ちではね
電池が10%になっても使い方によっちゃへ陣中物っぽいって本当にスマホの弱点つけ
たら結局そこなんですよね
電池がないからすぐ
電池が切れて何もできないんだって
5な妻本着てそういうところねディファイばね鋼
これだなん
ホームゲームでシンプルなグレースケールのテーマを適用して使用このアプリの数を
制限してバスで初球を抑えます o
うん
持って行きました基本的なもしか使えない点はブラウザメールだけかなと思いきやここ
でアプリがたせます
あれ
喉乾いてきたなぁ
水が飲みたいちょっとごめんなさい日水のおります
あれああ
延べもうすぐ伸びそう
ああ
あ
ってスマホにかかっても大丈夫な galaxy s 5から galaxy シリーズ
初の防水機能をって言ってるんでまぁどうせ機能は付いてるんでそういう心配を
なくなっちゃうって感じですネットワーク地これではで見ても世界一レベルのステック
持ってるって言われてるんで
2分間違いじゃないと思います s 4んでもだいぶ満足してるからさ
勝敗ですよ
反応がぜひちょっと使ってみたら良いと思いますっていうわけで
galaxy s が使ったことない俺が準急ラクティス5の魅力でした
ただねまだねかも全然他の機能も結構他の新しい機能をたくさんあると思うので是非
確認
チェックしてみてください
じゃあな
th
e 7